with tether the big question everyone
wants to know is is it backed one to one
to dollars and i'll i'll ask it that way
in terms of i think there's a bunch of
different ways you could answer but
that's what everyone wants to know is
can i have confidence if i hold tether
that it's actually backed one to one to
dollars how do you respond
so
if the answer is definitely yes
um
how you know that so
um it's it's in it have been in public
so in 2021 so just a little bit more
than one year ago tatter settled with
the new yorker in general and then later
on with the cftc
so um after uh the settlement especially
the first settlement tatar started to
provide what is actually the current um
standard for for civil coins that is uh
the attestation so
um with the attestation tether shows
that every
single usdt all the tethered tokens
are backed 100 by reserves
so um that happened um
pretty soon after this happened with the
new york attorney general and after
you know any process that is ongoing on
a quarterly basis so on a quarterly
basis
that there is um uh offering uh these at
the stations
and uh
even more so after the first attestation
that happened uh in february 2021 um the
the following one contained another uh
piece of information that at that time
no one was offering that was the uh
breakdown reserves so we went one step
further and started to provide the
breakdown reserves so showing how the
portfolio was composed right so we could
have
not have done that but yet we did and
then
of course that that
raised some questions especially on the
commercial paper side and then we went
one step further and we also provide the
breakdown of the rating and software
service right now uh it was um
made public that the vast majority of
all commercial papers are uh actually a2
or rated a2 or better or both so a2 a1a
um by uh you know not just by a random
guy but by the standard poor's that is
the agency that rates uh almost
everything in this world include the
treasures so uh the point we have been
always making is if you trade if you uh
trust standard poor uh with uh with the
ratings that they're prior to you know
all the all the classic instruments um
you should also rely on this on this
evaluation when it comes to
understanding the risk of terror also
we have provided um we have
been providing the this information also
to the new york authority general in a
quarterly basis and so on um so a long
story short at all the tether tokens
were are more than 100 percent back and
when i say more than 100 back means that
tether has um additional reserves that
are captured all the activity that that
has been doing over the last years uh
all the profits have been capped in the
company to increase the banking
um
so that uh
all there is an additional buffer
cushion uh for um backing the data
phones
awesome
when i give you dollars and i get tether
back
what are those dollars go are they being
lent out are they being held are they
being invested in bonds or some types of
securities that's the second big
question everyone has is like what
happens to the dollars when they go in
uh and as a way i think most people are
trying to underwrite like what risks
they have
so when um someone buys statter uh from
from teller.joe so you register on the
website to go through all the kyc
um and all these procedures to
ensure that you can
you are
a good participant from for the tether
primary market then these dollars go
into uh tethered bank accounts from
there there is um uh
they will be allocated to the portfolio
so just one important information right
we talked about the breakdown reserves
uh that showed that we had a
concentration of commercial papers um
that also we claimed in in um six months
ago that given the feedback we got from
the community
we would uh
we would start decreasing the allocation
of commercial papers and um in the last
six months the allocation of commercial
papers uh went down fifty percent why
i'm saying this because ask where uh
um the dollars that have been sent to
tether where they go right so their goal
in this
uh in this portfolio that is composed by
cash cash
equivalent
treasuries commercial papers and so on
so um
the the way we address there is is
through um a team of people that have um
you know
decades of experience in
in
managing uh portfolios
they also run a really thorough risk
approach so we on a weekly basis we
analyze the risk of the portfolio
using uh all the black swan events
including the 2008 crisis
um and we know that
in in all these situations all the
tether will be redeemable also it's
important to know when again you ask
about risk it's important to know that
uh um
we tattered never refused one redemption
at any point in time even when 2020 was
march i believe that we we just recently
got the anniversary it was the 12th of
march when uh donald trump closed the
month lines to uh us just the stock
market and also the crypto market
started losing um
a ton of value uh up to 50
and also at that point in time we never
had an issue in processing and
redemption
can you talk a little bit about what the
impact of tether on the market has been
uh obviously there's tons and tons of
people around the world that want to use
these new types of payment rails
but they want stable value so for
whatever reason whether uh they're right
or wrong they view bitcoin or ether or
any other cryptocurrency as volatile uh
in u.s dollar exchange price um and so
they want that stable value which tether
was the first to provide at scale
globally
what has been the impact of global
adoption here
well tether was born in 2014 and was the
first stable con right so nowadays
everyone who talks about stable cranes
about cec's we are discussing with the
regulators with central banks as well
and that was created um as
a simple idea actually because the idea
of that was
let's take the brilliant innovation that
that is
that was blockchain that was covering
power in bitcoin and applied to the
dollar so tether is a dollar and a
blockchain uh simple this is really
sounds simple now uh back in time when
uh
all the exchanges in 2014 were sending
back and forth wires and swearing
because there were the wires where
they're blocked or laws were taken like
several days to clear
that was a brilliant innovation
and um so
um was born as a way to optimize the uh
trading strategies of um crypto traders
because back in time that was tough for
in 2013 was the first time uh bitcoin
price went above one thousand dollar
and uh we were seeing uh spread across
the exchanges that were massive at some
point where spreads are around 20
and in any in any
financial industry of respect you need
to ensure one thing that is called
arbitrage so the arbitrage activity is
the thing that will keep the price of
the same asset uh in line across
multiple trading venues but in order to
do so you need to be to be able to move
to transfer funds
um the two actually the two legs of a
trading pair like bitcoin us dollar is
composed by two lakhs the bitcoin side
and the dollar side right so in order to
have a proper trading market and a
proper arbitrage across
multiple trading values you have to um
you have to be able to transfer bitcoin
and dollar at the same speed in the
traditional financial markets you would
you would send you know your your stock
um holdings and your transfer dollars in
in the same way because it you know it's
a cross-consolidating transfer but with
bitcoin is not the same thing so you can
move bitcoin at you know in 10 minutes
from one and change to another the
average block time for bitcoin is 10
minutes but dollars were taken from one
day to five days to clear and you know
your arbitrage opportunity was
was gone and arbitrage means basically
that you want to sell bitcoin on the
exchange where the price is higher and
then move back the dollars that you're
earning that way to the change where the
price is lower and then buy bitcoin with
those and transfer bitcoin way back to
the exchange where the price is higher
so you do this back and forth with the
important masses and then you keep the
price in nine of
right
and tether kept
kept growing due to this uh this
interest because you know we tether went
a little bit flat between 2014 and 2016
but then in 2016 exchanges like okay x
and then okay coin um actually then
eventually uob and then i recall
polonius was actually the the biggest
exchange at that time that started to
lease tether or all their pairs all the
crypto pairs all the new icos against
usdt
and then bitfenix had the same thing so
we started to see enormous arbitrage of
enormous advertising opportunities that
were eaten up by you know all the new
professional trading firms that were
coming into crypto
and they were all starting to use
stature and now today category is being
traded across almost every single
exchange i would say every single
exchange in this world
we have seen recently in the last year
or so that also
coinbase started to to accept the tether
and allowed attempted trading so tether
started as
a simple instrument and simple tool for
traders to optimize their training
activity to allow arbitrage but now
in the last 2-3 years has been
established as a you know cross-border
payment solution as a
remittancy solution as a you know
micropayment solution um when the with
the growth of the diff of the adoption
of different blockchains especially once
some ones with lower fees tether is more
and more used as an instrument for for
fast payments
and of course he's also considered an
instrumental freedom we are seeing that
with uh also the in and have been
accepted in ukraine by officially by the
ukrainian government government and also
in
the
democratic party the democratic movement
in myanmar they claim they they
suggested they said they claimed that
the tether was for them a legal tender
so uh it is of course is spreading in
many different directions um
really honestly many more directions
that we originally mentioned hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time